you know i think if you're the president
you gotta like have the quality to make
people feel
like everything's gonna be okay even if
it's not
i feel like that is like your job you're
supposed to go out and
talk to the whole entire country during
times of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and make everyone feel like it's handled
when you see donald trump you look at
him and say we're [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] and do you see joe biden
and he's like
everybody just climb we're less [ __ ]
he might be old but at least he's got
the [ __ ]
at least he's got the young fly sister
with her whack ass timberlands you know
what i'm saying yeah she had the one
souls yeah i'm like who's this like
the new york people was getting oh they
got to stop trying to like make her
hip-hop because
she said that the [ __ ] tupac was the
greatest rapper alive and i'm like why
is she even like
like come on leave it alone man just
leave it all and may the
the other way to look at that is maybe
she knows something we don't know maybe
tupac
is alive man she ain't the only one that
know that [ __ ]
bro let me tell you that out loud for
like
10 years of my life i try to nah
probably like five years that he left
the country now he's alive
bro there's so many things about tupac's
death that are wild like
if you listen to tupac's greatest hits
there's a song on there called uh
where he says he says rest in peace
biggie smalls in the beginning and
biggie died like
like [ __ ] nine months after tupac
died he said rest in peace [ __ ]
biggie smalls
and then at the beginning of machiavelli
he says suge shot me yeah he does i
heard that
bro there's a song on tupac's greatest
hits where he shouts out biggie being
dead
also there's uh he did
you know when they were putting out
those whack ass tupac albums where there
was like uh
just random ass like current rappers on
songs with tupac like why is
he shouted out trick daddy bro on one of
the songs and i'm like yo trick daddy
was not
a [ __ ] round bro in 96
yes he was yeah i mean but was he like
he would i'm sure he was around
but like was he like this [ __ ]
didn't know the [ __ ] trick that he was
bro like www.thug.com was like the first
album that had uh
i think that was like 99. like it was
99.90 no it was 99. look it up
was that a baby i'm a thug no that was
that was after
trick that it was popping it was the um
that was the nan that you know man
okay yeah let's see one you might be
right that i think that was like 98.99
it was 99 1800 or what's it though
trick's first album based on a true
story came out in 97. okay no but
the one that everyone knew him for doug
doug.com but if his first album what
year
97 what tupac died in 96.com is 98.
okay if his first album came out in 97
he was probably already moving in 96.
tupac died in 96 and for the record
but you all know [ __ ] didn't come out
in 96. 98
so 98. yeah listen man nobody knew the
[ __ ] trick that he was when chewbacca
was alive
god bless you yeah i could i could now
so tupac i was thinking this
[ __ ] was alive
i'm like wait a minute why is he
shouting out biggie smalls
that [ __ ] [ __ ] i know he had a lot of
songs but like
he's got like [ __ ] eleventeen albums
since he's
[ __ ] died like how much [ __ ] that
well that's your
your your knowledge back then no you're
right now that i know that was
that was when i was a kid but now i know
that there's [ __ ] who literally
have like 500 songs on their hard drive
that nobody wants
to clip pieces he could say biggie
smalls he could say
rest in peace and they go clip true
they can make him say anything yeah
that's true as a kid you don't think
like with the [ __ ] process we didn't
exactly we didn't know about the [ __ ]
boards and working in the studios and
like all that [ __ ] back dude
just like tv bro hold on i'm about to
play this part bro i used to listen to
this song so much as a kid because i
heard him say that i heard this
no you heard the shook shot me everyone
heard that but nobody never heard the
biggie smalls
people don't remember because people
ain't real tupac fans
and by the way i'm extremely critical of
tupac i think he's
one of the most overrated uh mcs ever
but i think as an artist he was
extremely important and incredible
um mc's mc break it down i just feel
like lyrically
like lyrics like lyrically
flow wise he was limited with his fl
like
you think a biggie biggie could hop on a
song with bone
and do bone [ __ ] like i just feel like
tupac
as the whole package was one of the
greatest of all time one of the most
influential but i think when we talk
about like who's the best rapper
like pure rap skills i don't think
tupac's i think he's around 11 or 12.
not that far back well i guess if you
because you're gonna get you're gonna
say
big daddy kane you're gonna say i put
royce the five
nine over tupac as a rapper if we're
talking about rapping
if we're talking about rapping i'm not
talking about making and by the way
royce is incredible
but i'm saying super though there's so
many artists who could wrap
circles around tupac
think of like this do you remember the
[ __ ] uh the biggie tupac freestyle
i got seven mac 11 is about eight
all you gotta do is just listen to that
song and there's just like a very big
contrast
on who was like the better rapper yeah
in the 357 [ __ ] yeah he's small
the millionaire the mansion the yacht
the two hot glocks the two spots
i got the weed spot i shot dread in the
head yeah they took the bread and the
lamb spread yeah
all right hey shout out to the tunnel
from funk flex and big cap for having
that
back in the day yeah see word
play yeah i'll say word play
that's what i'm saying i'm not saying
that tupac was not [ __ ] broke tupac's
one of my favorite
i got you under two bucks one of my
favorite rappers ever i got you but you
know what people die on the tupac cross
i found the song by the way tupac song
uh-oh
why is it not playing it's cause it's
[ __ ] what you tell us somebody about
it
the governor the government doesn't want
us to know tupac's alive bro
look at my new xbox hit the power button
it don't work
why is it not playing on my spotify
god bless the dead is the name of the
song pull up on youtube
listen to this [ __ ]
see see that's how it's clipped i would
have been through that play it back
watch watch this i'ma tell you why it's
clipped
whatever it is the [ __ ] is missing
the word [ __ ] is missing that's the
piece of my [ __ ] [ __ ] biggie
smalls they clipped it resting pizza my
[ __ ] biggie smalls don't nobody
talk like that bro
maybe tupac does the [ __ ] that you don't
know that man and
somebody in cuba probably knows him